aimez vous votre pizza végétarienne tout
garni ou encore avec extra glyphosate
selon des chiffres que nous avons
obtenus sur les centaines de pizzas
d'épicerie analysés par l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments 9
sur 10 contiennent du glyphosate sans
toutefois dépasser les limites permises
en 2015 l'organisation mondiale de la
santé déclare celui-ci probablement
cancérogènes le glyphosate c'est
l'ingrédient actif d'herbicides comme le
puissant et controversé roundup de
monsanto le problème au canada c'est que
ces herbicides à base de glyphosate
constitue 56 % de tous les pesticides au
québec 44 % de tous les styles
louise vandelac est professeur titulaire
de l'institut des sciences de
l'environnement de l'uqam et chercheur
au collectif de recherche écosanté sur
les pesticides on répand des herbicides
à base de glyphosate avant les cultures
au moment de la levée des plans juste
avant la récolte ce qui est interdit
également en europe et ce qui fait qu'on
en a beaucoup comme résidus dans
l'alimentation haut nil samuel et
toxicologue depuis plus de 30 ans à
l'institut national de santé publique du
québec là où le glyphosate a plutôt de
son importance et beaucoup avec la venue
des plantations des des cultures quand
j'ai n'ai donc le génétiquement modifiés
qui ont fait que loeb le projet de 10 à
grande échelle à travers la planète
de façon potentiel de 7 8 ans
donc dans les grandes cultures le maïs
le sorgho principalement
c'est extrêmement le produit le tout à
quai
[Musique]
dans les trois dernières années l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments a
testé près de 13000 produits de toutes
sortes représentant le panier des
canadiens un échantillonnage énorme est
plutôt inhabituel résultat un aliment
sur 3 contient des résidus de glyphosate
même la nourriture pour bébés n'y
échappe pas un échantillon sur 4
contient des résidus quand il s'agit
notamment des aliments pour enfants
je pense qu'on devrait prendre ça très
au sérieux notons que sur les douze
mille sept cent soixante sept produits
analysés seulement 69 dépasse les
limites maximales de résidus fixé par
santé canada
on détermine des valeurs de protection
ce qu'on appelle les limites maximales
de résidus qui sont faites quand même à
partir des données toxicologiques auquel
on ajoute plusieurs facteurs de sécurité
est théoriquement on devrait se sentir
en sécurité
lorsqu'on considère un produit contenu
hl de toutes les évaluations qui ont été
faites
ceci dit il demeure des incertitudes et
notamment pour le glyphosate on a tous
entendu parler de la polémique sur le
potentiel cancérigène du produit
frédéric bissonnette et responsable du
dossier à santé canada est vraiment on
vérifie les habitudes alimentaires
qu'est-ce qui comme les enfants pour un
peu de jus de fruits donc on va
considérer que les jus de fruits aussi
contribué à une certaine portion du
risque chez des enfants
donc on pas vraiment le panier
d'épicerie si vous voulez si on consomme
cpc s'est produit pendant toute là notre
vie qui contiennent une limite de
résidus de teint est ce que leur cycle
acceptable mais quand la limite est
dépassée ce que le produit rappeler ou
pas nécessairement à ce moment là elle
il faut comprendre les limites des
résidus donc c'est pas uniquement
uniquement mesures de sécurité un animal
dépasse avait prononcé mardi que le
risque la santé humaine était dépassé
c'est pas parce qu'on mange tel aliment
qui va avoir tel problème c'est beaucoup
plus long c'est beaucoup plus complexe
mais pourquoi exposer les populations de
cette façon là quand prétendument notre
première tâche c'est de s'occuper de
d'assurer la santé des populations et de
l'environnement
64% des légumineuses haricots pois
chiches et ceux ayant étudié contiennent
du glyphosate même chose
dans 58% des céréales comme l'avoine et
le blé qui sont à la base de la
fabrication de nombreux aliments
plus étonnant un produit biologique sur
4 contient des traces de glyphosate la
grande utilisation des choses a fait que
mal desservies présent la
l'environnement et on la retrouve
maintenant dans l'eau des rivières on la
trouve un peu partout donc des
contaminations croisées de culture est
de même des cultures bio
bonne nouvelle ce sont les fruits et
légumes qui en contiennent le moins
équiterre et le groupe environnemental
defence ont aussi fait analyser de
nombreux produits sans dépasser les
limites 80% des aliments testés en
contient tout de même eu mus céréales à
déjeuner nacarat ni au fromage
craquelins biscuits et autres tous des
produits de consommation courante
malgré l'omniprésence de ce pesticide
dans notre alimentation santé canada
vient de permettre l'utilisation du
glyphosate pour encore 15 ans comment se
fait-il que des instances publiques
autorise pour 15 ans donc jusqu'en 2032
sur la base une littérature qui ne
correspond absolument pas la littérature
des 15 dernières années entre autres de
reconduire pendant si longtemps alors
que l'europe n'a reconduit pour cinq ans
alors qu'en france on cherche vraiment à
s'en débarrasser d'ici deux trois ans
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
ce qu'on nous dit c'est que les
conclusions de santé canada sont
semblables à de nombreux autres agences
réglementaires en europe on parle du
bureau allemande analyse du risque
f sort qu'il agence européenne de
sécurité des aliments et cas on parle de
l'allemagne
on parle du japon on parle de nouvelle
zélande de l'australie des états unis
qui arrivent tous à la même conclusion
que santé canada donc nous on est
confortable victoire à notre test notre
décision
des scientifiques s'étonnent par contre
que les études consulté par santé canada
proviennent presque exclusivement de
l'industrie vous dormez bien la nuit
avec un détenu des études non seulement
de saint-aubin d'autres compagnies on
avait accès aux données brutes en contre
x que nous permet on prend pas l'analyse
de monsanto après les données brutes de
l'étude et autres calculs nous mêmes et
on pourra nous faire notre propre
conclusion le glyphosate est un des
nombreux pesticides à se retrouver
chaque jour dans notre alimentation et
on ne connaît pas les impacts à long
terme sur notre santé il s'agit surtout
pas de dire on arrête de marge et je
pense que il est très clair qu'il ya
possibilité bon manger davantage de
fruits et légumes c'est toujours une
bonne chose
boire davantage l'eau mais surtout
s'assurer que les normes et critères
pour tout ça et pour les légumineuses et
pour les céréales correspond davantage
aux normes notamment européennes qui
sont nettement plus exigeante que les
noms
[Musique]